on va continuer à parler de cette
attaque à l'armé blanche avec alexandre
landon glowria syndicaliste vigie police
bonjour avec son nom vous remercie
d'être avec nous sur rt france cet après
midi là alors notre reporter nous l'a
dit il ya quelques instants
une enquête est ouverte auprès du
parquet antiterroriste qu'est ce que
cela veut dire concrètement ça veut dire
par cas terroristes anti terroriste
majeur inscrit contre le terrorisme
effectivement la localisation le
contexte actuel peuvent laisser penser
c'est ici pied la plus probable à
l'heure actuelle donc ils vont enquêter
pour faire le croit savoir si réellement
stéroïdes qui doit être villégier ou pas
me dire quels pouvoirs publics prennent
la piste sérieusement
alors on le sait maintenant l'un des
suspects a été interpellé dans le
secteur de bastille un suspect qui était
couvert de sang au moment de son
interpellation les policiers seraient
pas la recherche d'un autre suspect
comment s'organise cette traque à la
traque cela le diable serait a priori ne
est celui qui correspond à des vidéos de
surveillance du quartier donc à ça
s'organise avec la diffusion de son
portrait des photos de la vidéo
surveillance et de continuer aussi de
surveiller par les autres caméras de
vidéo surveillance et la traque
s'organise ce dès le début pour que la
personne soit localisé dans un périmètre
assez proche de son lieu d'action est ce
que après malheureusement plus le temps
passe il ya de chances qu'on ne la
retrouve pas tout de suite on l'a dit le
quartier ce quartier du 11e
arrondissement cette rue à perth est
allée verte tout ce quartier vraiment
est bouclée mais qu'est ce qui se met
exactement en place dans ce quartier et
jusqu'à quand jusqu'à quand ça va
dépendre jusqu'à temps que ce soit utile
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où
pense qu'il ait retrouvé la deuxième
personne est retrouvée ou alors c'est
trop tard parce qu'elle s'est éloigné
parce qu'après on peut boucler un
quartier pour faire des recherches ma
propre à le garder a bien fini mans
bouclée parce que bien des gens qui
doivent vivre dans le quartier des
enfants qui doivent retourner
donc il faut savoir faire la part des
choses entre les deux est là la
préfecture de police pour répondre à ces
questions sur la durée sur le planning
vous parliez tout à l'heure
du contexte on va on va le rappeler ce
contexte actuellement le trio tribunal
de paris a commencé le procès des
attentats de charlie hebdo
c'était en 2015 des attentats tout court
de 2015 la drh de charlie hebdo a été
évacuées de chez elles
récemment c'est difficile de ne pas
faire le lien entre toutes ces affaires
difficile vu le lieu où ça s'est produit
les attaques se sont produits il est
difficile encore moins vu que les
pouvoirs publics ont saisi le parquet
antiterroriste et on va voir ce que va
donner la suite ce qu'on a pu voir que
sur certains attendent a aussi en se au
début on était parti sur la piste
d'attentes alors que c'était des gens
qui avaient des brassards problèmes
psychiatriques et qui aurait dû tout
simplement être interné donc et aussi ce
côté là là la médecine ou les hôpitaux
psychiatriques ont pas forcément les
moyens de travailler contrôler tous les
malades qui devraient être enfermés et
c'est la police si les passants qui en
font les frais donc allé aussi ça cette
piste à ne pas exclure parce que c'était
d'un couteau donc ils n'ont pas beaucoup
de préparation la dernière fois que
charlie hebdo pour les procès qui sont
en cours la plaque était beaucoup plus
préparé ce n'était pas juste des gens
qui étaient attaquées comme ça devant un
couteau
justement à le mode opératoire de de
cette attaque me change un peu forcément
des attentats terrible que l'on a connu
en 2015 il semble cette fois ci être un
peu moins organisés est-ce que c'est
vers ce genre d' attaque l'on se dirige
aujourd'hui malheureusement pas toutes
les attaques sont possibles mais c'est
ce qu'avait annoncé à l'époque d'âge
dans sa communication quand il était
encore actif le en syrie et ils avaient
annoncé que mam étant allés faire des
attaques au couteau fallait faire des
choses avec les moyens du bord donc les
gens qui peuvent tomber dans ses dérives
sectaires parce que pour les choses un
chat un chat c'est des dérives sectaires
qui embrigade des certaines personnes
soit fragile psychologiquement soit qui
sont en rupture avec la société qui ne
se retrouve pas les ombres égale les
groupes de leurs reproches et c'est donc
on est vraiment sur une dérive sectaire
qui produit des attentats ignobles
donc oui on peut s'attendre à en avoir
de plus c'est les plus difficiles à
détecter est-ce que ça demande pas
beaucoup de préparation donc là c'est là
où le renseignement humain est le plus
important avec les gens qui connaissent
ces personnes qui peuvent nous donner
des fois des indices sur le comportement
qui a changé ou des déclarations qu'ils
ont pu faire récemment donc c'est là où
il faut un maillage
fin du renseignement français ont c'est
un clin services de renseignement n'ont
jamais arrêté forcément de travailler
sur les piste terroriste on sait aussi
que plusieurs attentats sont déjoués
chaque année qu'est ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui que certains arrivent quand
même à passer entre les mailles du filet
a déjà tout simplement parce que on peut
pas être à peu près tout éviter on ne
peut pas tout contrôler nous sommes cent
cinquante mille policiers et quelques
centaines de milliers de gendarmes en
france
donc de toute façon face à la pologne de
peu d'habitants en france on ne peut pas
tout contrôler on ne peut pas être
surtout l'émission le savoir par le
renseignement tous les policiers ne
travaille pas au renseignement
donc à passer tout ça qu'il faut
travailler les plus gros sont et pts et
les stratégies et si chacun travaillait
comme le renseignement territoriale ou
la drpp ont pas tous les services de
renseignement français et travaille
c'est que on ne connaît pas les
résultats sont qu'il n'ya pas l'attentât
mais des fois difficile de communiquer
dessus ce que les enquêtes en cours des
réseaux qui seront démantelés donc le
travail ne se voit pas mais il est
efficace derrière et le risque zéro
n'existe pas à moins d'habiter dans un
état où tout est contrôlé chez tout le
monde ce qui n'est pas souhaitable en
france
est-ce que la première crainte aussi des
forces de police aujourd'hui en ce
moment même ce n'est pas ces attaques
simultanées des attaques qu'on avait
connue en janvier 2015 en novembre 2015
aussi des attaques qui ont eu lieu au
même moment mais dans plusieurs endroits
de
de la capitale c'est toujours une
crainte mais ces attaques la simultanée
nécessite une organisation une
logistique et celles là ont beaucoup
plus de chances d'être détectée par les
services de renseignement en amont et
éviter donc évidemment on a toujours
cette crainte mais c'est celle qui sont
les plus prévisibles en tous les cas où
il ya plus de chances que les intercepts
avant qu'elles se produisent alors on a
vu des membres de la police scientifique
en les voit justement sur sur les images
à côté de vous certainement procéder aux
premières analyses quelles vont-être
quel va être le rôle de cette police
scientifique dès maintenant dès
maintenant c'est de pouvoir comparer les
personnes qui peuvent être interpellés
ou appréhendée pour comparer s'il n'y a
pas des traces d'éden ou des empreintes
vérifiez également que les gens qui ont
des traces et indices qui pourraient
être relevés sont pas des gens qui sont
déjà fichés ou dans les fichiers de
police donc se permettre aussi
d'accélérer les enquêtes et pour la
suite pour les procédures si jamais ça
devait les camps seriez pas au tribunal
ça sert de preuve ça sert de démontrer
qu'ils étaient là qui n'était pas là
merci beaucoup pas langlois d'avoir été
avec nous cet après-midi sur les
antennes d'ayrté france on viendra bien
sûr vous vous voir lors de nos
prochaines éditions je rappelle que vous
êtes représentant du syndicat vigie à
police on